Well that was inputs, now let's look at outputs.
In particular the outputs produced by the concrete operations along with any
changes made to class attributes and
other side effects must satisfy the abstract specification.
Among other things this says the answers that your implementation give
had better satisfy what is required by the specification.
Stated in logic.
If we have some concrete state t, and the invariant is true, and
the preconditions are, the concrete preconditions are true,
and the, after executing the operation the concrete post conditions are true,
then it better be the case that the abstract post conditions are true.
Parsing this one step by step like we did for the inputs.
Valid concrete states as the part that says that for
all t element of the set of concrete states, capital T would be invariant.
The concrete invariant must hold on that state.
And the concrete preconditions are satisfied, and
that's the Pre-Q sub i on t and whatever arguments we have.
And running the country operation satisfies the concrete post conditions.
That's the phrase with post Qi on a concrete state.
The arguments, the resulting concrete state T apostrophe, and
whatever results are produced.
Then the post condition had better map to the stated abstract post condition,
the last part of our post logic.
Which say's the post condition on the abstract operation Pi,
with the retrieve state, the arguments, the retrieved version of
the resultant state, and the results produced had better hold.
Note that as you might expect, the implement, the implementation can do
more than what the spec says as long as it does at least what the spec says.